[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum murats fünf
minuten
heute mache ich mein erstes haben wir
ein rezept ja ich freue mich riesig
drauf und zwar nicht sagt murat fünf
minuten manchmal auch mehr
keiner hat gesagt die 45 minuten ich bin
ich auf jeden fall
und heute mache ich ein ganz cooles
rezept das nennt sich katrin ich mach
das heute eigentlich ein genie
normalerweise meine fünf minuten rezepte
aber da ging es auf eine schwarz
baustelle muss streichen und deswegen
machen das alleine mit dem wolken
zusammen
volkan hier volkan ihr kennwort ein
vielleicht schon volkan interpol kinder
auch hier ist meine und die wolken ist
teil unseres teams der macht ja auch was
und zwar schon seit über einem jahr
der vulkan ich werde jetzt von volkan
merken wir hatten an komischen akzent
wenn er kommt aus der türkei volkan
nicht wolfgang und sein akzent kommt
daher hat er jahrelang in london und
dubai die wie gewohnt deswegen hat er
nicht diesen türkisch deutschen aktien
sondern diesen englisch deutsch und
englisch deutschland ist nicht perfekt
englisch und türkisch und deutsch
spricht auch schon sehr gut geht ja ich
mag es wenn ich kann ein bisschen im
nebel wolken immer ein bisschen englisch
reden meine englischkenntnisse
aufbessern
volkan was tust du bei uns in der firma
als sehr kurz ja ich mag die sein und
sagen ich sehr mag und die produkte ja
nein ich mag viel einkaufen
der titel ist im product manager für
alle hauptschüler sowie ich zum beispiel
erst arzt purchase and product manager
also arzt so ok und im wolfgang wolf im
vulkan zusammen machen kann es wolken
versteckte sales germany engelshaar
kennt ihr vielleicht könnte man töten
fertig schon kaufen und zwar ist es
meistens 500 gramm packung
aber ich gebe euch ein ganz großen tipp
wenn ihr das beim türken kauft guckt
bitte auf das
haltbarkeitsdatum wenn ich fünf mal zu
töten ist es vier mal abgelaufen
und ja ich sagen soll verstärkt auf die
rückseite um schimmel ist weil das ist
ein frischeprodukte damals 500 gramm und
das machen wir jetzt auch hat die open
des android und jetzt machen wir da 300
gramm rein
ich habe meine hände gewaschen ich höre
ja 300 gramm haben wir jetzt und jetzt
zumindest volkan auseinander
naja wie ein huhn oder wie brokkoli
übrigens immer neuen sagen manche
behaupten
ich würde die veganer immer auf die
spiele macht nicht oder wie brokkoli mag
ich den bekannten sich zu ernst nicht
richtig toll durchgelegen ja ich es auch
viele vegane haben und die nicht einfach
eine tolle ernährung
[Musik]
wir sind ja aber nicht jede wieder
gehabt nicht jede übergaben jetzt
kämpfen seite an seite nicht gut wir
haben oder soja ich versuche immer
manuellen okay okay volkan ich habe das
jetzt der proton ihre das genau geboten
auf englisch debatten mattenleiter ok
button erstmals muss gelegentlich ja
okay war kann jetzt haben das bisschen
ding gemacht so macht auch spaß richtig
lüftet ja jetzt verteilt ist in diesem
mai blick dieses immerhin stattliche
induktions geeignet wenn sie mal
interessiert und müsste es wissen will
mit uns in baku richtig ok
[Musik]
die backen wir zu uns ja gar nicht dem
backofen mit ihrer olympia richtig ja
noch okay jetzt hat es da rein gemacht
und jetzt was man als nächstes kind das
rezept meine fragen aufgeschrieben was
man bei sex ist das ist man die zutaten
hinzuschauen sagen
ja so genau ach gott tut mir leid ich
zeige euch mal die zutaten was wir
dieses tolle rezepte für den teig
braucht ihr 350 gramm butter 150 gramm
zucker 100 gramm pro 100 gramm
haselnüsse und dann braucht ihr noch
engelshaar 300 gramm misst 1 5 gramm
packung der rest könnt ihr so jetzt
haben das engels haben verteilt wie
gesagt des engels hat in den
orientalischen gemüseläden meistens
konzerten oder wenn ihr wenn ihr kein
töten bräuchten mehr gehabt weil er
vielleicht aus erfurt kommt dann kann es
auch sein
da könnt ihr euch zum beispiel auch so
ein passt dass er tot
und da ich es mit drin dieses engelshaar
ding
keine ahnung ich bin kein verkäufers
solle produktplatzierung sein so das
ding gibt es auch gar nicht zu kaufen
es könnte gar nicht haben weil das hat
mich manchmal weiter dann habe das
engelshaar in der in diese in diesem
gleich ausgebreitet ihr könnt auch jedes
blech nehmen sagt egal
richtig reich dreimal ja ok und dann
machen wir jetzt machen die
kg ist - okay dann hast du es und in der
zwischenzeit wo der vulkan hacken kann
er kann gut mal als veganer kannst du
das waschen gemüse erfahrung mal fleisch
denn ich hatte vielleicht hätte man zu
schneiden aber hacken kann er gut
am zweiten tag fleisch auf die fragen zu
stellen wir haben keine antwort jetzt
folgendes ist der zwischenzeit tue mir
in der potocari schmelzen schmelzen
jetzt wie schmerzen oder werden in der
sugar okay das war okay jetzt immer
diesen topf und zwar nennt sich das satt
war diese schmerzen und zwar gleich das
du an
er ist auch nie die hitze im topf immer
zeit geben zum erwärmen erst noch nie
die hitze und dann hochschalten so ok
wolken kennt sich aus das ist übrigens
ein messer
es ist ein typisches gemüse mehr richtig
drücken sich gegen auch bei der 100
das ist gut wir arbeiten zusammen beide
hände und jetzt schon mal die butter
rhein zum schmelzen und nicht zu heiß
ist auch mit einer hitzig wo es geht
aber schnell nicht
wie lang ist die vulkanwolke lang ist
ein vulkan seit mittag begann wollte
zwei jahren drei jahre jetzt aber das
ist auch kein problem wenn jetzt jemand
gleich ist so wie ich habe das ist mein
okay das heißt als seine entscheidung
ja ich bin und spiele ich würde sagen
das ist meine schuld aber bei understand
ja das ist gut für mich
aber wenn jemand möchte essen fleisch
oder der produkte ja ich respektiere das
ist die andere person entscheidung in
anderen zitiert haben ja okay dann haben
wir hier die butter das ist fast fertig
so jetzt haben sich die butter
geschmolzen ist und dann machen wir
erstmal zurück
roger ist drin auch noch ganz schön viel
butter geht also man kann auf 50 km
warum weiss jemand weiß jutta im angebot
war so und jetzt können wir den zucker
dazu zucker ablöschen macht man
natürlich nicht aber dazu kommt rein
und jetzt riecht es nach butter und
zucker
volkan wie weit ist wie im hacken und
butter und die zucker das wird nachher
die masse die nachher indes engelshaar
einzieht das wird richtig dass sich
richtig auch für ich denke für
europäische verhältnisse und wie butter
so viel zucker aber orientalischen hat
man nicht viel mit mit zucker gemacht
ganz ganz extrem viel
am anfang ist es vielleicht zu viel aber
es schmeckt wirklich genial
jetzt habe ich den zucker auch drin
jetzt nämlich ein vulkans gehackte
walnüsse begann er zu 100 prozent
jetzt mache ich die mit 3 jetzt riecht
es nach butter zucker und man kann ja
nur recht gut fast fertig die
unheimlichen trick geht ja warum
und die hat man sich ja ich hab noch
keinen hasen so ist das halt ein
bisschen okay doch mal rein
dass dazu richtig cool das ist so
typisch orientalische ich sage auch im
orientalisch weil die türken machen so
jahre aber machen so die libanesen
machen so allem also okay dann haben wir
das gemacht und jetzt kommt es
insbesondere und zwar nehme dieses kader
engelshaar und werden dass damit trinken
die hand ich wiederhole noch mal meine
hände gewaschen
jetzt wurde es richtig schön trinken und
zwar in der ganzen zuckermasse und jetzt
tun wir das richtig schön gut verteilt
und ja keinen gefallen wenn er denkt es
ist zwar nicht so flüssig dann macht
jetzt ja kein wasser rein oder so geht's
einfach ein bisschen cool hier nochmal
verteilen das ist richtig schön ins
engelshaar einzieht
das ist so richtig wird wie beton
ja ja ja betont sich auf erfolg hat auch
eine ins trio sein geheiß beton artwork
der ist auch künstler der macht das
kulturinstitut mal rein bei betten
artwork und abonnieren ok jaja aber
nicht die hacker nur die normalen nicht
nur um eine masche so jetzt tue das grab
ein bisschen hochschalten bisschen an
rüsten lassen in der zwischenzeit räumen
wir auch
[Applaus]
während es hier an rüstet jedoch immer
mal ein bisschen rühren die hitze etwas
hochschalten und jetzt habe ich
folgendes mit den wolken zusammen
gemacht und zwar dann nimmt ja einfach
ihr könnt es machen ihr wollt denkt nur
mit beim backen und zwar haben wir hier
ein dritter jetzt around ja ok und dann
nehmen wir hier becking red back in the
slammed genau und zwar nennt sich das
auf dauer back to back folie ja dann
machen wir das drauf und stellen es ein
auf 25 sorgten eingestellt 25 und jetzt
das ein bisschen analysten noch ein
bisschen kommt dass man noch richtig
knallen
da ist der trick ganz ganz wichtig
solange es aussehe wie sauerkraut ist
noch nicht ist noch nicht richtig fertig
es muss richtig knusprig sein
sauerkraut in englisch kraut kein kraut
ok richtig schön karamellisiert muss es
seien ja nicht aussehen wie sauerkraut
[Musik]
so jetzt immer so weit sieht aus wie
sauerkraut aber ein bisschen dunkler
sauerkraut und ganz ganz wichtig nicht
anbrennen sich auch wichtig aber
trotzdem ruhig zeit lassen
brücher vor hitze und jetzt volkan jetzt
kannst du die hälfte
es kommt jetzt kommt nämlich der trick
jetzt nimmt er wollte die hälfte von dem
topf und tut sie hier rein
ich habe hier schon das sind vorbereitet
so und der boden wird jetzt auch richtig
hart weil die butter die zieht sie jetzt
wieder zusammen mit dem zucker so jetzt
könnt ihr hingehen
ein cooler trick das macht meine frau
bei no big boat würden immer gerne
dann nimmt dir einfach diesen penny
richtig peinlich stampfer und stampft es
richtig schön in den boden reicht
richtig schön fest die butter erkaltet
jetzt mit dem zucker zusammen die ganze
nüsse und ihr seht wir haben den perry
drücker zweckentfremdet und jetzt sehen
wir den boden
jetzt haben den boden fertig und jetzt
machen wir im wolken zusammen
die füllung und zwar richtig coolen
pudding projektarbeit der bohne ist
eigentlich ziemlich süß müssen sagen
schmeckt einfach richtig cool
und jetzt brauchen wir noch so was ein
akzent noch so ein bisschen die frische
reichen nicht zu süß nicht und deswegen
den man diesen pudding und was wir für
den pulli für zutaten brauchen das ist
sagen wir jetzt für den pudding
benötigen wir ein liter milch 50 gramm
mehl 50 gramm stärke ein teelöffel
natürlich ist ein extrakt 1 esslöffel
orangenblüten wasser ein gramm 100 gramm
zucker 100 gramm kokosraspeln 100 gramm
butter und für die deko später noch
gehackten pistazien
jetzt machen wir die coole füllung wie
gesagt nämlich einen akzent setzen
für den knackigen charakter boden und
jetzt ist es ganz ganz wichtig da müsste
jetzt darauf aufpassen und zwar jetzt so
die füllung machen und bei der füllung
bei den pudding machen ist ganz ganz
wichtig erst die zutaten kalt verrühren
damit sie keine klümpchen bilden das
heißt ein bisschen milch rein und zwar
ein bisschen heiß von milito
ein halber und dann tun wir das mehr
dazu unter ständigem rühren oder kam es
zu hören ja ok unter ständigem rühren
wichtig ist mag keine klümpchen bildung
genau
erst galt zusammen wenn man auch die
stärkeren dann immer die die
kokosraspeln genau schön verrühren
wir rühren rühren den zucker danach
nicht fehlen sagt jawohl dann immer noch
ein teelöffel vanille extrakt
natürliches vanille extrakt ein
teelöffel schwupps ist bei euch immer
mehr aus ist aber wir haben große wasser
aber eigentlich orangenblüten wasser
gebraucht jetzt tue ich einfach
natürliches aroma rey und zwar 12
tropfen kreuzung orangen rosenblüten
zwar noch wenn euch das heer kriegt
engel bei uns oder im türkischen laden
bekommt ihr das auch große wasser und
orangen masse bekommt überall auf dem
globus oder im interspar das ist richtig
richtig richtig große ranch motto und da
wolkig mit weiter und jetzt mal langsam
erhitzen
und wenn es jetzt aussieht als visconti
machen macht es nicht weil es die
kokosnuss bin wie gesagt bei mittlerer
hitze ganz wichtig beim pudding ist ganz
ganz wichtig das ist das ist der tod
jedes puddings ist wenn ein anbrennen
nicht richtig habe ich recht hast du
schon mal ein pudding gemacht ja das ist
gefährlich pudding ist immer gefährlich
immer ständig rühren und jetzt langsam
die restlichen butter milch mit rein
richtig vulkanbehörde
leider leider ja man könnte aber auch
man könnte sie noch realisieren ja ja ja
selten sehr leicht ja ein anderer mich
und mandelmilch gegen total fertig
man nämlich kurz das vierfache ein
bisschen ja ok köcheln lassen will ich
sagen auf mittlere sicht nicht kochen
genau und immer ständig hören weil es
darf nichts anbrennen das ist der orden
schmeckt dann wieder durch angewandte
frühling schmeckt wirklich nur gegangen
[Musik]
kühlen lassen und dann noch mal zum
schluss die butter 1
die mutter ist natürlich einen coolen
geschmacksfrage aber die butter sorgt
nachher auch dafür dass massa abkühlt
dass sie fest wird habe ich recht ja
dann muss ich natürlich welt ich habe
jetzt mal in der kochsendung sind jetzt
wird die butter eingerührt perfekt
wolken ist okay und jetzt kommen wir zum
nächsten schritt und zwar habe ich da
was hingerichtet
und zwar ist das hier das fleißige
lieschen wenn ihr das nicht habt dann
könnt ihr ganz normales haar sieht
nehmen und wenn ihr es habt habt ihr
nämlich glück dann geht es schnell kann
jetzt nämlich dass hier gerade hier ein
okay
und das ist dem ist mich richtig cool
ich weiß hat man für meine frau mit hand
gemacht und ich habe es auch nur machen
müssen
[Musik]
jetzt ist nämlich das was wir nicht
haben möchten also meine frau gesagt sie
möchte die kokons für mich drin haben
und eine ganz ganz feine sehen wie die
masse den geschmack von den kokosflocken
habt ihr ja wir können alles aufgekauft
habe trefft der rest kommt bürger wissen
superteam ja wahnsinn als etwas anderes
gemacht
wir sollten zusammen der patisserie
griff
[Musik]
und jetzt und deswegen auch das
aufkochen und die ganze zutaten bei
jetzt muss es nämlich so sein dass der
pudding sich erhärtet weil wenn der
pulli zu flüssig ist und ich setze
darauf künstlern das an der seite raus
läuft deswegen machen wir das nicht und
jetzt tue einfach ein pudding hier drauf
[Musik]
bei uns jetzt ein bisschen unbeholfen
aus bei meiner frau ist noch ein
bisschen professioneller und jetzt nimmt
man diese ist immer noch den rest von
dem von dem von dem kater richtig und
kann daher genauer schon hart geworden
gern ja ja und jetzt macht muss noch
genau
[Musik]
das betrifft ich genial es riecht so
genial brückers ok man kann es machen
ich mache meine hand
[Musik]
wenn natürlich jemand noch jetzt
masochistisch veranlagt ist kann er noch
schokolade gregor kippen kann auch noch
machen aber wir wollen es nicht
übertreiben das ist cool leather fazit
werden jetzt natürlich ein fehler nicht
machen wenn wir einfach jetzt ein rein
weiß möchte davon sich entweder machen
wir aufmachen und zwar geben wir das
jetzt wirklich vier schon in die kinos
umso wenn er sich ins gefrierfach geht
jetzt noch schneller aber mindestens zum
kühlschrank mindestens vier stunden
kühlen und mit der 4 stunden gekühlt hat
er ist dann zeigen wir wieder aussieht
richtig alles klar also im kühlschrank
was bei dem rezept auch ganz wichtig ist
wenn der ball kann ich zwei fähige leute
werden werden wir jetzt eben das
innerhalb von 20 minuten fertig die
macht sich ja wenn wir wüssten wo immer
alles werkzeug liegt wo das ganze zeug
legt da wenn man 50 und fertig gewesen
aber wir haben einfach keine ahnung
haben und erstmalig diesen genau das
wissen länger aber ansonsten ist es
rezept 20 fertigt ihre schulzeit perfekt
und greife ich will mehr und ich denke
mal mindestens rauskommt sieht es aus
als dass wir eine aus einer türkischen
partie sahen also in der küche alles
naturschutz im kühlschrank und nicht
okay wir schon spieler holger geht's
weiter
jetzt habe ich die torte aus dem katla
so habe ich jetzt aus dem kühlschrank
holt ja weil es einen obs mäßig gebacken
hat und jetzt jetzt kommt es natürlich
dass tricky ding
dafür braucht eine jahrelange erfahrung
meine frau ich habe schon mal ich hab da
schon mal nach sally gesehen braucht es
geht so passau und zwar hier das ist ein
top messer und dann gehe ich hier
entlang
[Musik]
so krass das macht meine träume alleine
und wir sind müssen es zu zweit machen
waren okay und jetzt lese ich den ring
ich gehe noch mal sich sicher bevor ich
habe keine lust habe so viel zeit damit
verbracht das ist richtig glück
[Musik]
überschrieben perfekt jetzt hat der volt
kann ich uns mal überlegt jetzt machen
noch einen drauf weil wir es jetzt
richtig richtig noch kohle haben möchten
jetzt haben uns überlegt dass wir uns
noch schokolade drüber machen richtig
brücke ja genau und dazu in der heutigen
methode dr wolke hat die methode
methodisch ganz einfach wir haben hier
eine teekanne die haben schon erhitzt
das wasser drin
machen wir es drüber und jetzt kann man
in tripolis über zwei drittel entwickelt
das heißt ich will hier rein und lassen
das jetzt schmelzen
jetzt tun wir das auf der schiene oder
schokolade drin war dabei jetzt 23 wer
schokolade drin und jetzt macht das
letzte drittel rein damit kühlt die
schokolade ab auf die ideale temperatur
ich glaube meine frau hat man 38 grad
war ich weiß jetzt richtig ist und das
sorgt dafür dass die schokolade keinen
grauschleier bekommt zwar so richtig
schön glänzend ist und damit die
konsistenz noch etwas geschmeidiger
bisschen sämiger ist tut mir jetzt noch
mal ein bisschen palmöl rein weil ich
beim öl schuldigen oder palmfett
kokosfett coesfeld ja kein palmöl das
macht nur verehrung wir machen das
natürlich nicht kokosfett und jetzt
haben wir eine richtig cremige
konsistenz und jetzt kommt der der
triqui moment bekannten und zwar habe
ich das noch nie gemacht
du musst da rein und zwar wird die
schokolade jetzt bei reihen laufen
lassen so dass nach einlaufen in den top
hits beutel
wir können nicht einen anderen beutel
neben eines anderen herstellers ich habe
reingemacht wolken während der vulkan
hier ein knoten reimer habe ich
folgendes ihr habt uns war habe ich hier
schon sani vorbereitet wir sahen die
schlag erschlägt haben wo ich zeigen
dass wisst ihr ja und deswegen tue ich
das erstmal ein bisschen verzieren und
zwar nehme ich das hier oben macht es
jetzt nämlich dass sie drauf und macht
die tipps drauf
[Musik]
neu kann wie mach ich dass sie das bevor
ich koche ich muss sagen ich habe auch
von ines sprit oder button
man kann sich schöner machen übertreibst
nicht wir sind wir sind keine profis
wir sind aber heiß kommst du jetzt
kann's noch volkes machen wollten
wahnsinn wie war ich das war perfekt
ein vom staat hier genau deswegen wollen
wir jetzt noch hier oben kann hier aber
wird europa ziehen sie ja nicht nur
mitglied und pistazie übrigens im
supermarkt in der in der
schmuckabteilung vulkan confessions
volkan mein freund ist ja ok wahnsinn
eine coole tore gemacht jetzt braucht
man jemand jetzt probiert ja ja kennt
jemand einen superguten den fernsehmarkt
problem ist aber inzwischen meine frau
vom zahnarzt kommt mit den kids erstmal
gespannt ja also angst aber ich habe
auch zum ersten mal glaube ich spritze
ich hoffe dass ich mich gut ja so schaut
es ist klasse und ich muss erst mal ein
video machen wegen mich mit sprit
techniken ohne spaß weil ich habe es
echt jetzt war er nicht schatzi maximal
nie ein bisschen cool
alles passt jetzt mal ganz ehrlich ein
bisschen ausweisen und ihr müsst jetzt
aber ganz ehrlich sie als auch wenn es
nicht schmeckt da muss auch sagen es
schmeckt sagt es auch okay
nein er muss das probieren schatz du
nicht lügen
[Musik]
und es war ich muss sagen es ist auch
voll einfach und wenn wir mehr ahnung
hätten von dem was ihnen auch schnell
gewesen
ja also wir haben halt viel 55 - no weg
ist richtig cool in der ferne gereist
[Musik]
und ich glaub wir hatten probleme wolken
hattest du probleme richtig zum beispiel
wundert das nicht zu süß ich jetzt sagen
wir mal schmeckt oder schmeckt s nicht
ins kann papa seine torten welt machen
ok
bis zum nächsten mal mit 1 5 minuten
[Musik]